so so since last year I've received many
emails probing the question of symbolism
and its relation to the Christians
insistence on the historical existence
of Christ just last week I was sent
something which summed up what was the
issue and so I'd like to read the main
parts of this letter that I received
last week and then I'll try to answer
some of its concerns okay so I'm 20
years old and I spent all of my grade
school years at a fundamentalist
evangelical Christian private school in
Forth Worth Texas there I was educated
and immersed in a deeply conservative
theological tradition however after I
graduated I began to doubt my faith and
progressively adopted a rationalist
positivist worldview and became an
atheist I have been an atheist for a
little over a year I had been an atheist
for a little over a year when I came
across dr. Peterson's lecture videos and
with those your videos dr. Peterson's
perspective opened my eyes to a very
different essential conception of
religion from the ones that I grew up
with and helped me rediscover a sense of
meaning and purpose in my life after
wandering aimlessly as an atheist I had
begun reading other great singers to
help further my newly developing
understanding of religion and
Christianity like Carl called Carl Jung
and William James here is where my
problem begins
I would now say that I certainly believe
in God an objective morality I would
also say that I believe that Jesus
Christ is the son of God and the source
of salvation but I think perhaps that
this is true in a symbolic sense rather
than in a physical literal historical
sense more and more I am convinced that
the symbolic reality actually points to
the truest reality but this concepts
conception is difficult to square with
the way that most people interpret
Christianity for example my peers and
teachers from my old school
would not consider someone with these
ideas a true Christian because to them
salvation depends on a faith in the
literal life death and resurrection of
Christ I noticed that this specific
point was also emphasized that one of
your fellow speakers father Theodore
Parris get vocalist in the resurrection
of logos talk all this being said I'm
just trying to learn and I know that my
overall graphs are these things so far
is totally minuscule this leads me to
the questions I have for you if you're
still willing to try to answer them one
in your view what beliefs really make
someone a Christian - how much of the
Bible do you think is symbolic truth
versus physical fact 3 you personally
believe that Jesus lived historically
and physically rose from the dead as
told in the Gospels for if you think
that the gospel story is symbolic how do
you get along with your Christian
community and lastly 5 for what reason
do you align with Orthodox Christianity
specifically so I've seen similar
questions arise around I've seen similar
questions arise around the type of
questions that have been asked of dr.
Peterson and I've seen on different
study groups that people have felt a bit
confused and frustrated by some of the
answers or at least felt like those
answers didn't fully answer their
concerns and so I'm going to try to
answer this as much as I can and I'm
going to try to answer those the
questions that were posed all
simultaneously so I think that the
problem firstly arises because we still
hold on to a kind of simplistic
materialism kind of 19th century
modernism which thinks that the fullness
of everything exists completely out
there exactly as we perceive it a kind
of neutral range of measurable phenomena
which we can then add meaning to so in
this view symbolism is opposed or at
least its divorce
from this truly objective world and if
in stories and myths and music or in art
we find these patterns of meaning
they're like an abstract layer that we
let's say subjectively add on to an
idiosyncratic and random world the
problem is that that's just not how it
works the problem of believing we're
only let's say enumerated physical facts
and a story is problematic because
there's constantly an overwhelming and
seemingly unlimited number of facts all
the time around us when we look into the
world there's this field of potential
being and so we have two faculties that
help us to deal with that the first
faculty is attention it is our capacity
to focus on something we focus in and
limit the world within our purposed
activity at any moment and so we don't
hear or see the same things when we're
cooking or marveling at a sunset or
shaving let's say the second faculty we
have to deal with the unlimited number
of facts is memory most of the things we
encounter around us just vanish and
there are specifics we don't remember
them our memory only remembers the
things which are important to us for one
reason or another our memory will string
things together string events together
into coherent hierarchies and narrative
structures these structures or these
stories they are already patterns we
often don't perceive the patterns but
the structure of why we remember
something or how we then order events
for others is already symbolic symbolic
in the sense that they are ordered and
pattern around things that have meaning
and then you have to see that there's a
kind of positive feedback
the feedback loop between attention and
memory and then between attention and
memory relating to other people I mean
everybody's aware of this I mean you
know people and I know people who when
they tell you let's say how their day
went they'll just ramble on and on about
disconnected and irrelevant things that
happened to them and when you're
listening I mean it doesn't take long
like ten minutes will do and you just
wish you could run away or you feel like
you're going to die of boredom so so
symbolism is not opposed to a kind of
neutral physical reality rather
symbolism is the very manner in which we
perceive and organize the unlimited
field of information one of the first
things that I remember that struck me
when I began to attend an Orthodox
Church I went to a talk that was given
after a service and one of the
parishioners was explaining how the
Greek word symbol refers to a place
where two things meet where two rivers
become one river for example and that
symbolism does not come about by adding
a kind of metaphoric meaning on top of
events but is the very bringing together
of events the formation of analogies the
process of synthetic compression of
multiple level of events of patterns of
relationships and it's the bringing of
all those things together which
constitute symbolism but also
constitutes the very manner in which we
engage the world so if some people are
interested in pursuing this I put a link
in the description of an article that I
wrote which talks about this more in
more detail I don't see there is no
reality which is not symbolic the nature
of our existence in the world is
symbolic events coalesce around centers
of meaning through our attention and our
memory we all experience
is constantly and if one is attentive
what it does it makes the world a
magical place I mean let me give you an
example we learned recently that my wife
is pregnant this was not planned at all
it was a complete surprise
but a few weeks before she became
pregnant three people close to us had
dreams of her being pregnant and then
the day that she did a pregnancy test
and found out she decided not to tell me
right away and wait until we had a bit
of time together that evening we went to
an event where we ended up discussing
with a couple that we barely knew who
had brought their the newly born child
and the man was asking us if we plan to
have another child and I was like no
we're done you know three is enough and
I utterly embarrass myself
it seems you know saying that we're not
going to have any more children and then
when when we we went we were leaving the
event and we went into the car I started
the car and the radio was already on and
then right away as the car started the
song that was playing on the radio with
a song about a woman who was pregnant
and going to have a baby and I mentioned
that to my wife said that's weird you
know considering the discussion that we
just had with that couple and so this
type of synchronicity the the type this
type of events coalescing in a manner
which is not causal in any scientific
way is something that happens to
everyone
and it is only maybe the pathological
fedora wearing a theist who would deny
this to himself
now it's easy to look back and say well
if my wife had not been pregnant then
all her friends would not have
remembered those particular dreams I
mean we dream all the time right
at the same time if she not found out
that she had been pregnant that event
where we discussed having another
maybe and and and then hearing that song
on the radio probably would not have
stuck in my memory very long I mean we
had all kinds of discussion that evening
with other people and so the cynic might
say it's only because she is pregnant
that all those former events became
important and were noticed by us in
forming a pattern and the answer to that
cynicism is yes that's right and you
cannot escape that the process of
putting together important things is how
reality works because our existence in
the world is symbolic human
consciousness orders and gives meaning
to an indefinite potential of existence
the world does not unfold randomly and
and if in some ways it does
consciousness attention and our memory
does everything it can to fit things
into a pattern all the random things
vanish and the margins of our perception
and if there is something truly random
something which both forces itself on
our attention and then pushes itself
into our memory we formulate that thing
as into the category of chaos of tragedy
of suffering it's a monster and we have
to contend with it so that we can
continue I mean if I am forced to
remember something which is truly random
it's probably a car crash an accident of
some kind or something that completely
disrupts erupt like a revolution into
the regular pattern of my experience now
in terms of remembering events there is
there's a personal way of remembering
events there's a communal way of
remembering events a broader social way
and I would even contend that there is a
cosmic way of remembering events and all
these levels of attention and memory
will not appear the same the more we
move away from the idiosyncratic how my
day went stories the more we move
towards
remembering events which have universal
significance the more this memory will
appear symbolic condensed it has to be
so that it can be attended to and
remembered by larger and larger groups
over larger and larger spans of time
there there needs there are specific
idiosyncratic objects or ways of doing
things which much much which must
disappear which much must be made to fit
with a larger and more universal image
or universal images so that they can be
remembered so for an example in the
Bible you can actually see that and the
very unfolding of the large story the
more you go back let's say towards
Genesis the more the stories appear
condensed symbolic Universal the forms
are compressed through images that
reveal more and more meaning so does
that mean that what's in the Bible does
not describe events of course it
describes events the problem is that we
think that all events are the same we
think that Adam which means man as such
ate the fruit of the knowledge of good
and evil becoming self conscious of his
mortality having been tempted by a
serpent is on the same level the same
type of event than when I'm picking my
nose or washing the dishes that's the
problem
the events in Genesis happened they're
just being remembered at a cosmic level
using narrative structures and images
that compress so much into them that
people have written thousands of books
unfolding the implicit meanings
contained in those primordial stories
there will be no one writing thousands
of books of how I did the dishes last
night it's like
if any event in the entire world has
definitely happened
it is the story in Genesis - and the
fall and just because computer brains
like sam harris cannot perceive cherokee
and being cherokee of events and a
hierarchy in the manner in which we
describe events just means that they're
forced to discount those stories to
their peril and to our peril the stories
which our ancestors for thousands of
years considered to be the most
important and foundational stories
foundational structures of our being and
the underlying origin of what it means
to be human and then you wonder why
everyone is so confused and
disillusioned and so when the question
is asked whether i believe let's say
that the resurrection of christ is
physical fact or symbolic metaphor i
don't know how to deal with that
question i mean what do you mean what
would you expect do you expect the
telling of the Resurrection to fit some
kind of technical description like the
kind of description a police officer
would give at a crime scene
how could it and why should it the
problem with the resurrection and with
miracles in general is the modern person
thinks that the point of the story is
understanding a kind of technical
description of what happened their minds
immediately trying to calculate the
miracle in terms of something which
could be reproduced through scientific
method and I just want to slap myself
when I see it is obviously the
resurrection by it's telling is
referring to an event but why do you
think you know what that event is why
does that event have to fit the level of
analysis you want to impose on it look
at the story itself even the way it is
told first off no one witnessed the
actual resurrection even in the story
when the people encountered the risen
Christ they don't recognize him at first
the disciples on the road to Emmaus
walked with cry
and talk with him without even knowing
who he was I mean there are numerous
details in the story which are there to
tell you that you should not presume to
think that you know what the
resurrection is now I believe that the
resurrection is an event yes but it is
obviously an event which is not
described directly for a reason which is
told in a matter which should avoid a
kind of forensic analysis so the
Christian have to believe that the
gospel described events yes the
Christian has to believe that those
descriptions have the modern
journalistic or forensic type of
description no the Christian has to
believe in the resurrection of the body
yes we need to technically described
like a surveyor would give a detailed
analysis of a terrain what the
resurrection is no the resurrection
imposes itself as the culmination of a
giant pattern a pattern which includes
the natural patterns of death and
rebirth the seasons the rotation of the
cosmic bodies a pattern which includes
all the stories of the escape of the
underworld the crossing of the flood and
all the other tales of life rising out
of death found in cosmic stories we
remember and attend to until today even
in in our movies and in our TV shows
video games comic books and the story of
the resurrection is everywhere if you
can see it until that brings me to to
the final part of the questions that
we're asked the reason why I chose
orthodoxy the reason why I told
orthodoxy has to do with all of this we
believe that the world is symbolic our
services our prayers the manner in which
we remember through the Bible through
the legends and tales of the saint is
because we know how memory and attention
have certain forms how they lead us to
and keep us in the heart
in the memory of the center let's say
we're not bothered by stories which do
not fit the rigorous forensic
description of a crime scene because we
know that such a description cannot will
not and should not be remembered but our
stories as they join the cosmic pattern
as they participate in the eternal
pattern they will have a memory eternal